candyman is a movie about an artist
named anthony mccoy who goes in search
of the candyman legend and ends up in a
rabbit's hole of horror
it follows a journey of him discovering
more about this legend the legend sort
of coming back to life and the trauma
and pain that kind of comes with it
candy man candy man candy man candy man
don't say that
and this scene in particular is um
anthony
with an art critic who's kind of done a
reverse on her opinion of his work
and um
it's what happens after he's dared her
to say candy man five times in the
mirror
ah
finley
wow
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
are you all right
i thought
what
i gotta go
[Music]
so
so some of what you're hearing in the
moment where anthony's looking into the
mirror and sees the reflection of
uh sherman
some of that is sound effects
but a lot of what you're hearing
underneath that i've done is create this
composition that has a lot of voices in
it and and i was thinking about
you know sort of speaking to this idea
of apparitions
sort of layering the victims of voices
past as well as sort of this this really
piercing high pitch
which is a lot of fm synthesis that's
moving around and i wanted to really be
able to excite the ear
and play with psychoacoustics in that
moment so it's
everything is really moving around
and also playing with this idea of
illusion and the construct of what is
reality and what is fantasy like it is
is
what's happening
doing so in real time or is it uh this
sort of almost like dreamlike state um
so that's what i was really thinking
about in that moment yeah i really love
um what you're saying because that was
so much of what we were trying to do
which was like
it's sort of like psychological warfare
through sound you know it's like will
the nightmare ever end but at the same
time like with that high-pitched sound
that comes in at the same time i really
find myself leaning into it which i
think is sort of anthony's whole like
fatal flaws he's like oh this is very
dark and scary but i'm i want to keep
going in and leaning in more and um and
i think the sound and and the score that
you built just does that so well like
mirrors that journey so well yeah i was
really thinking about the way that the
characters were choreographed inside of
the scene in the mirror having mirror
image movements of each other and then
there's this really dense
low end thud that happens when it cuts
to
the hook and the hand
[Music]
where it's this almost a slow reaction
with almost a breath being released
where it's almost like
the that threshold which is the mirror
has been
almost sort of breached and then also
right at the top of that scene when
anthony's sitting in the other room
after finley has gone to the toilet just
before that they're having this this
conversation and the sound that you
start to hear is this sort of whirring
like feedback with these voices like
tucked into it that are sort of
careening like very very very low
underneath but it's it's almost like
his his position as the acolyte is
starting to open up
ah
i love that sound that you put there
um with sounds that you put there at the
top where he's waiting for finley
because in the sound design we also have
like the they were just listening to
like being on apple's latest record and
yeah and they get to the end you sort of
thought of the
at the end
and and i think i feel like those two
things match each other so well um yeah
so i like love that how the soundscape
starts and where it goes i think
the things that i try to avoid with with
a genre-based film is is leaning into
tropes i think that
so often you hear
very specific very canned
sounds or or a sonic palette that's
attached to any sort of a genre and
i want always want to be able to move
away from that i think for me one thing
that you know that we
discussed a lot in the beginning was
the original film and the original score
and how
it's a very
peculiar score that philip glass ended
up making for
that film and you know it's not out of
the the realm of possibility that uh
a
20th century composer
would
do a genre film like a horror film but
the the
particular sound palette that he used
for that film was was something that was
quite a bit different and really
interesting and i wanted to be able to
provide that
in a way that was freestanding from the
legacy with a certain nod to it but
being able to create like basically
build a world
in which
the
the language or the vocabulary that i
had made was very specific to this world
which lives in the universe of the
original film but its own story and it
is its own work
and so
this this scene actually
something that i think is really
interesting about this is the fact that
the core of this composition that's in
this scene i wrote
while i was working
nia with you and katrine in l.a
um
that's where this started and it was a
really it was a really great way to work
because we were working in the same
space
and
you guys could work on the edit and show
me the things that you were working down
and then i could take that
back to my room and sit and work
and work through an idea and then bring
it down the hall to you and so it was a
really interesting way of working
and
one that i think worked really well and
for this
particular moment
it's a lot of it's a lot of fm synthesis
um which is you know basically it's it's
like early digital synthesis
where it's a lot of sine waves stacked
on top of each other which which produce
a
a bell-like or a glass
like sound
it's very ringy and belly and
glass-like
um
but then also the this sort of uh
squiggling that you start to hear at the
end of the
uh the composition
as the summoning has already happened
and
anthony is is has
come to this realization
knows that something bad is happening
and is is trying to retreat
i was using this object which is um
basically a contact mic inside of a
block of wood with these
um uh
metal rods in it and i was using that
and i was bowing
these metal rods which created this
really sort of creaky
tense sound
and so being able to
make an electro acoustic work in that
moment and use an acoustic element with
an electronic element and then also
coupling that with the voice
the sort of choir voices that i made
like singing to this you know sort of
i wanted it to
almost be
siren-like
if that makes any sense
yeah definitely yes yeah you know and i
want to feel them drawn in
[Music]
i wanted it to be
inviting
with consequences if that makes any
sense there's definitely
something wrong but you're compelled to
move towards it so yeah dude that's like
i'm just like remembering all like the
conversations we've had and also just
like
the the story is so much about like
every time you tell me candy man
you you are basically asking for it like
you know exactly what you're doing and i
said i think this siren's call is so
like important like the way you phrase
that like it's so true and it's so much
like
like i think sometimes in scores you get
like sounds you're like oh i don't like
the sound of it kind of like making you
want to turn away but this is like oh
this is really weird but i need to lean
into it um
which i which i love and then just to
speak to like kind of like avoiding
cliche i remember
i when i was looking at this again uh
the part where um
you know revealed that sherman slash
candy man's in the mirror um there's no
jump scare sound yeah and i know we
talked a lot about like i think we maybe
have like one moment where there's like
a jumpscare sound but we talked about
like that's just not this movie like
this is not like
you know like sort of yeah no scratchy
violin moment and and
that i'm so happy we're on the same page
about that because i think that just
makes the movie
really live in its own world yeah
yeah i think it really does i think it
has a very unique signature i know i i
really wanted to do
going into it which is why i was so
happy when ian introduced us at the i
think was like us premiere after party
whatever yeah um yeah and he was like
hey
robert like just you should just meet
him and i'm like okay you know you
created this like unique specific world
of sound and
and i think it really shines especially
in this in the scene
i thought
what
i
was really excited about this death i
guess in particular because i it's a
kind of a more somber moment it's a more
grounded moment i think even though
obviously he sees a demon ghost in the
mirror um but it's like you have these
this moment of
deep character grounding
and i wanted to make sure that with
finley what we get wasn't just like okay
he killed her i also wanted it to be
okay he killed her but like what is the
context of like what is the greater
world in which this is happening and how
does that world feel about this
happening and so pulling out from that
window was my way of kind of showing
kind of like urban disinterest
in a way
i'm born and raised in new york city and
i love it here but it's also very
strange bizarre i think all cities are
strange bizarre place where like
amazing things happen miracles happen
and also horrifying things happen and we
all kind of just go about our lives and
so i think
in the same way with finley
part of the reason also why i dropped
out the score there is because i just
wanted you to hear the city
because what you hear is not a woman
screaming or you know her guts falling
onto the ground you just hear people
going with their lives and you see
people in other windows watching the
football match and or game that match um
because it's american football um
and that was really
important to me that we
we've had a moment to
to live in that which is kind of morose
and depressing but you know it's also
candy man so pulling back when you have
the perspective outside of the building
you you have a greater understanding of
the context of the structure
which
uh in in a way is is mimicking a beehive
you have
this event that's happening inside of
the hive and the
greater world outside is just like this
sort of microcosm that's happening
inside of this
mythology and that's why i held that off
until the end like i didn't want to
establish the building and then go in
and you know i wanted that to be the
last thing that you saw um
i think establishing shops are obviously
very nice of their storytelling but the
way you use them can be you know you can
hold them off you can just use them in
different ways and and having that funny
film image at the end when can't arrive
i think it's really important
why i wanted to work with him well one
robert sent me like a bunch of like
tracks like just a bunch of um
music and
um we ended up actually using that um
in in some of it's in the movie and then
but all of it uses like temps for when
when we're playing movie but from that i
was like oh when this person really gets
gets it gets what the boss is doing um
his brain is insane i don't know what
going on in there and i love that um and
um and she's a lovely human being so
it's just really like you know the uh
the things that are really important to
me incredible talent um and diligence um
a brain that is uh unique and exciting
to to to
see a glimpse inside of and also a good
person so
um that's that's why for me
[Music]
you